des films en HD au grenier à celle c'est
la nouveauté de la rentrée pour le
cinéma de quartier de trappe
l'installation a nécessité un mois et
demi de travaux et répond avant tout à
un besoin technique et oui dans quelques
temps sen sera fini de la pellicule au
revoir le projecteur 35 mm de papa place
aut tout numérique la résolution des
projecteurs dans les autres salles c'est
une résolution 2 cas c'est-à-dire 2000
points par ligne 2000 pixels par ligne
nous on a choisi un projecteur 4K donc
4000 point par ligne donc la résolution
de l'image est quatre fois meilleure
parce que il a deux fois plus en hauteur
deux fois plus en largeur de point c'est
un projecteur du futur en fait c'est la
venir on a acheté ce projecteur là de
meilleure qualité pour ne pas avoir à
faire les mises à jour dans quelques
années dans quelques mois le système est
géré entièrement par informatique les
films sont livrés sur disque dur et non
plus sur pellicule une évolution
positive selon les responsables de la
salle avec néanmoins un défaut comme
toutes données numériques peut y avoir
des problèmes on commence aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a Batman ce soir et déjà
le disque dur qu'on nous a fourni ne
marche pas donc il faut retrouver un
autre disque dur pour pour Batman ce qui
est fait on a trouvé un autre disque dur
au cinéma de saciè l'école qui nous
l'ont prêté gentiment l'installation de
l'appareil et les travaux de rénovation
ont coûté près de 100000 € mais pas
d'inquiétude le prix des billets reste
le même l'un des objectifs étant
d'attirer de nouveaux spectateurs
dernière précision il s'agit bien de
cinéma numérique HD et non pas 2 3D
cette technologie n'est pas encore
disponible au grenier à sell un choix de
la
municipalité